Saving us from soaking, scraping and scrubbing,
Teflon has been a lifesaver (or at least a
hand-saver) for home cooks for the last 50
years.
Comprised of a unique polymer that actually
repels nearly every other material (the only
known thing a gecko’s feet can’t stick
to), the processes used to get this substance
to adhere so well to a pan relies on sand,
heat, a vacuum and sometimes even another
chemical.
For the uninitiated, as noted previously,
Teflon was created by accident in 1938 in
Dupont’s Jackson Lab.
Dr. Roy J. Plunkett had been playing around
with refrigerants and compressed and froze
a sample of tetrafluoroethylene which spontaneously
polymerized.
The waxy result of that experiment was polytetrafluoroethylene
(PTFE).
Inert and, for a long time, “considered
the most slippery material in existence,”
PTFE became known as Teflon in 1945.
The trouble with Teflon is that PTFE is a
fluorinated polymer – a long chain of identical
molecules.
The molecules are comprised of carbon and
fluorine, enmeshed in one of the most powerful
bonds known, with the carbon atoms surrounded
by a “tight helix of fluorine atoms.”
Along with this super-tight bond, fluorine
also naturally repels other elements, and
together, these two properties keep things
from sticking to Teflon.
Because repulsion happens in all directions,
it would be impossible to get Teflon to stick
to a pan without help, and there are a few
different ways this is done.
One method, said to be used for Dupont’s
Silverstone brand, begins by sandblasting
the pan, creating an uneven surface that encourages
adherence.
A primer layer of Teflon is sprayed on, then
baked at high heat that helps the Teflon get
“a secure mechanical grip.”
Note that this is a mechanical, and not chemical,
adherence that some have characterized as
similar to the way ice cubes get stuck in
a tray or Velcro binds together.
Depending on whom you ask about Dupont’s
process, the initial sticking is followed
by one or two more rounds of spraying and
baking before the pan is considered finished.
A second method also bakes the Teflon onto
the pan (called “sintering”), but first
involves subjecting it to a barrage of ions
in a “high vacuum under electric field.”
This forces some of the bonds holding fluorine
atoms to break, allowing the carbon underneath
to bond to other materials, like oxygen, which
allows it to stick to the pan.
The third method is similar to the second,
except that the changes to one side of the
Teflon are done with a reducing agent that
breaks the strong bonds between the fluorine
and the carbon allowing the fluorine to bond
together.
This leaves the carbon free.
The free carbon, which forms into unsaturated
hydrocarbons, is sticky enough to get the
Teflon sheet to
stick to
a pan.